Speaker 1: One of the really sick things that's
happening in the United States is that instead
of everybody coming together to get beyond
the pandemic to encourage people to hey, if
you have a reason to go and get tested, go
and get tested and let's support testing and
let's grow the number of places where you
can get tested.
There are people harassing those going and
getting a COVID test.
I'm going to play a clip for you.
In a moment of anti-vaxxers, COVID truthers
and other types of conspiracists in New York
City yelling conspiracy theories that people
who are trying to get COVID tests at one of
these corner pop up clinics.
Now, we don't know exactly when the clip was
filmed.
The clip was recently released, but from the
way people are dressed, it doesn't seem like
it's that cold in New York City now.
At the same time, a couple of days ago, it
was in the mid 50s in New York City.
So this may be very recent or it may be a
little bit older, we don't know.
But let's take a look at the video and what
you're going to hear.
If you're just listening is people yelling
conspiracy theories and berating people getting
tested.
You get tested.
Why?
So, you know, if you should stay home and
not give this thing to other people, it's
a good thing to do.
And here are anti-vaxxers and conspiracists
attacking those getting tested.
Shut it down.
Speaker 2: These are faulty.
The PCR test?
Yeah, this what's creating all these big numbers
and creating more fears with
Speaker 1: fake PCR tests are creating fake
numbers which are creating fear.
I'll I'll address this substantively in a
moment, by the way.
Mo, this is this horrible story.
Speaker 2: Whenever there's not
Unidentified: one thing that can be testing
to create a big no no for Dr. Government
Speaker 2: officially signing
Unidentified: your life.
Do you guys know we've got the invented a
PCR test that the term monetary policy invented
in the 90s that
Speaker 2: you are about to take?
Terry McAuliffe said that the PCR test is
not accurate at all.
You guys, you and I use it to figure out if
someone has a disease.
The positive is that it indicates
Unidentified: to the person that in fact,
in your test, you guys listen to the person
that invented the PCR test.
They don't even recognize the patient while
there are no longer term.
This is adding.
And propaganda you're pushing we're
Speaker 1: getting tested leads to propaganda,
Speaker 2: propaganda.
That's right, and a positive test is militaristic.
These there's a big Jillian faces.
Unidentified: I wonder where all those bazillion
codes
Speaker 2: came from a fake test.
Getting a medical procedure on a dirty, rat
infested Manhattan street corner, getting
a medical procedure.
Kerry Molas, Kerry, Moez, Kerry, Moez, Kerry,
Mullah's Kerry Mills, Kerry as PCR maker Kerry
Mills, Kerry.
Speaker 1: All right, so you get the idea.
Obviously, police should be called in these
situations, and there's a bunch of different
things to talk about.
First of all, if you believe in my body, my
choice.
Leave people who want to get a test alone.
Don't harass them.
Let them get a test.
You don't.
Nobody's forcing you to get a test.
What happened to my body?
My choice.
But let's address substantively, substantively
what they're talking about because I keep
getting emails about this as well, saying
the inventor of PCR said the PCR test isn't
accurate.
Let me explain to you exactly what is the
truth about this, because it has been misstated
and misstated and misstated a PCR test measures
the presence of a certain viral proteins.
OK.
It is true that I could imagine that someone
coughs on me who has COVID.
OK, I breathe in some viral proteins and they
are now in my nose.
I get swabbed, the swab is tested and it's
positive for viral proteins, but I'm triple
vaccinated, my body could be fighting off
those viral particles and the viral particles,
thank goodness, don't replicate and I don't
get an infection.
Certainly, it's conceivable that if you swab
me at the exact moment where those viral particles
that someone coughed on me or in my throat,
that I get a positive test and I never get
sick because my body fights it off, that's
possible.
What the PCR test measures is the presence
of that virus in the body.
It can't definitively tell you, Are you sick
with COVID?
Do you have an active, contagious infection
or did you have just enough viral particles
in your system to trigger a positive test
and then you didn't actually get sick?
That's true.
Generally speaking, the timing of that specific
situation I mentioned is very, very rare,
and it doesn't mean that PCR tests shouldn't
be used, can't be used aren't of diagnostic
value.
It is true.
It is true that you could have the presence
of virus and not be actively infected.
It's a very small portion of people and it's
not really relevant to testing strategy in
the way that these people want it to be.
Now, unfortunately, this anti testing stuff
is actually spreading in Florida.
Florida has a pretty wacky Surgeon General,
Joseph Ladapo.
He says it's time to unwind this testing psychology
prioritized by the federal government.
You don't need to go and get there.
He's saying, do less testing.
Don't be so worried about going in testing.
Here he is.
Speaker 3: We're going to be working to unwind
the sort of testing psychology, right, that
our federal leadership has managed to unfortunately
get most, most of the country in over the
last two years.
Speaker 1: Right.
Testing problem Now just the federal government
is making too many people want to get tested.
Let's unwind it.
We don't need tests and we don't need testing.
Wow, what a strategy.
By the way, have you seen Florida's numbers?
Speaker 3: We need to unwind this testing
sort of us sort of planning and living one's
life around testing.
Without it, we're going to be sort of stuck
in the same cycle.
So, you know, it's really time for people
to be living to, you know, to make the decisions
they want regarding vaccination.
Yeah, to enjoy the fact that many people have
natural immunity.
Speaker 1: There you go.
Oh, man.
Meanwhile, Florida, you'll be told Florida's
doing great.
Florida hospitalizations are up 200 percent,
even if Akron is indeed less severe on a case
by case percentage basis as we believe it
is.
Florida with a skewing older population does
C plus 200 percent in terms of hospitalizations.
So a lot of horrible backwards things going
on with something as benign as testing, and
that does not bode particularly well.
Let me know what you're seeing in your community.
Find me on Twitter at the Packman.